[Music]  it makes me feel guilty  we know that re proposes to someone yeah  do you think being this torn that he  should have proposed my one issue with  art after watching the finale my one  issue would be that why why would you  take that step if you're so torn don't  feel like you have to get engaged like  don't put that pressure in yourself  because it's gonna ruin the whole  experience it's gonna ruin the whole  story I don't know why if you're torn  you would get down on one knee and make  it so you don't think you should have no  why would you get down on one knee that  still doesn't make sense to me if you're  so conflicted we're humans like we're  not perfect and we're gonna have some  confusing thoughts but why do you get  down and make a commitment if you're  that conflicted if you're that  conflicted maybe you just asked for some  more time or you asked for another week  of the show I don't know but it's just  hard for me to understand how you can  down one knee